The jogan Experience like I grew up
riding dirt bikes and like I love doing
[__] I'm like but our job so dangerous
already I'm like I can't afford to to do
any of these other things like we were
up to mountains over the weekend like my
brother's like let's go snowboard I'm
like bro like I can't dude like I want
to so bad but I'm going to do all that
[__] when I'm done fighting like you
just can't stack another thing on top of
[__] like I have a I have a Ford
Raptor I got it all souped up I'm like
that's my that's my thing you know like
I got a nice truck but I can't I can't
ride bikes yet I can't like we just
can't afford to stack all those other
things on top of our dangerous ass job
already did you see what Sean Strickland
was doing the other day shooting like
like Roman candles at each other a
firework fight yeah bro I'm not doing
that three weeks before he's fighting to
to he had like burns on him he's so nuts
he's nuts he's so out of his [__]
mind but that boy can
fight all he does is Spar he probably
looks at he looks at a treadmill he's
like get the [__] out of here he's like
I'm going to go Spar what's crazy is his
conditioning like look at that Israel
adna fight this his first time fighting
for the title he's fighting a legend and
in the fifth round he's not even
breathing heavy floors him too amazing
amazing hits him with that onew drops
him pummels him afterwards and then but
dude he's like he's not even jumping
like dirt bikes he's jumping like
motorcycles in the desert like what the
[__] is this he's out of his [__]
mind and that's also how he blew his
knee apart oh oh yeah cuz he used to
fight 70 people don't know him and
kamaro fought at um at 170 back in the
day kamaro put it on them pretty good
well I think he's one of those guys that
really was cutting too much weight he's
definitely he's hug that point of
diminishing returns that'd be like Joey
trying to cut down the 170 like you'd be
[__] just cuz you can make something
doesn't mean you should do it you know
like it's I'm going to be interested to
see that fight next weekend I can't
believe see the extreme version that
watch that TJ documentary it's pretty
heavy his fight with drus is going to be
uh very interesting draus is [__]
scary that and that's a guy who's so big
for 85 the way he looked against uh I
counted I didn't give him a [__]
chance against Robert Whitaker and boy
was I wrong because well also that's
after he got his
DV which I think I mean it's a big
factor being able to breathe out of your
nose you can't breathe you can't fight
but it's also it's like drick is looks
awkward when you fight he moves
different but that movement and that
awkwardness makes him difficult to time
it's like his timing is off and if you
don't have anybody that can imitate that
kind of Stutter Step motion that he does
yeah he f f weird yeah it's deceptively
technical though deceptively it's his
style you can't you can't say it's wrong
you know like that's how that's how he
fights and it works and he's like you
can tell he's strong like I think he's
going to come in and really try to like
put like a hard grappling Pace on Shawn
and but Shawn's hard to take down like
you don't see many guys taking Sha down
like he's not well he's a very good
Grappler he's not yeah he's not easy to
to take down I've talked to guys roll
with him like that [__] is very
good he was out at um I think he was
training with jao and those guys yeah
yeah Jo told me yeah Joo goes dude he's
[__] legit yeah he's really legit too
like I'm sure he has good good Jiu-Jitsu
yeah but that's that's a good fight well
here's an interesting statistic because
you know the UFC was it a mouth guard
that they gave you guys show how many
shots you take something like that yeah
he gets hit the Le
and like his defense is so
underappreciated that was a big factor
in that fight too OS just couldn't find
him yeah he's like like it's like a
weird like Philly shell that he does and
then he's lifting that like lead leg to
like teep yep he's front kicking you
with that lead leg Yeah and that and
he's just always jabbing like and it
comes like you would think a jab coming
from down here like it'd be easier to
time but it's not cuz it's coming from a
like you don't [__] see it and then
bop bop and then you say continue with
the jab but it [__] it works for him
it works for him amazingly I don't think
Izzy was 100% in that training camp
either like he had that that DUI thing
or DWI like right before that I was like
two weeks before that fight and I think
he just thought he was going to [__]
blow Shawn out of the water and Sha's a
tough [__] and after the aboose
fight you someone should have looked at
that fight and go looken this guy is
always there he's always there it's
crazy how it can flip so fast like a
year ago he lost to Jared caner and now
he's [__] UFC champion yeah oh I mean
how about the the P fight yeah he gets
Flatline in the first round against paja
and then you think this guy's not going
to be the champion a year later he's the
champ champ yeah and went to train with
P yeah that shows you how yeah he's like
I'm gonna go learn from this [__] guy
P will teach you which is even crazier
oh
yeah